good morning welcome to sky news
breakfast
all adults in the uk should be offered a
coronavirus vaccination by the end of
july
as the prime minister this morning
promises an acceleration of the rollout
boris johnson says this will help
protect the most vulnerable
and enable an easing of lockdown
restrictions it comes as nhs england
confirms more than two-thirds of people
aged between 65 and 69 have now had
their first jab
just a week after invitations went out
our people and politics correspondent
nick martin reports
it is an ambitious target that all
adults will receive their first covid19
vaccine by the end of july
and all over 50s before then by april
15th a sign perhaps
of the government's confidence in this
herculean national effort
this vaccination site is one of 1500
nationwide
what's critical of course is that as
many people as possible
are vaccinated because the more who are
vaccinated
the more individuals are protected and
the more society as a whole is protected
the task ahead
is to get into the next priority groups
that jcbi have recommended
and then of course dependent on what the
government recommends
uh we'll be jabbing uh into the summer
with more than 17 million people now
vaccinated
the prime minister might feel confident
that he can plot a route out of this
crisis
care homes have already been told that
residents will be allowed a visitor
from march the 8th and schools are
bracing themselves for a return
around the same time despite concerns
from teaching unions after months in
lockdown
all eyes will be on the pace at which
restrictions are eased
so i just can't wait until you can get
back out in person and share you know
share the moments that we've all had
and we have known and grown up with it's
been explained to me that until
the actual infection rate comes down
it's best to stay shielding so
his his um whatever he says on monday is
not going to make much difference to me
probably the schools will be open and
like universities and classes back to
normal probably that will be the
biggest part of it today key cabinet
ministers will meet to finalize their
plans before the prime minister
reveals the so-called road map on monday
afternoon
boris johnson knows there's an awful lot
riding on this move
too fast and he risks another wave too
slow
and he risks damaging the economy and
people's lives further
but look at the language the prime
minister is using
he says the route out of lockdown will
be cautious
and phased the success of the
vaccination program
remains pivotal to the government's
recovery plan
nick martin sky news westminster
let's take a look now at the latest
coronavares figures for the uk
10 406 new confirmed cases of covid19
were recorded in the most recent 24-hour
period
a further 445 people have died within 28
days of testing positive
that brings the uk total to 120 365
and 17.24 million first doses of the
vaccine
have now been administered
the labour leader shakir starmer has
called for all schools in england to
reopen by the 8th of march
setting himself against education unions
who've called the move
reckless the opposition leader was
speaking to sky sophie ridge ahead of
tomorrow's announcement by the prime
minister on easing the lockdown
the prime minister is updating the
vaccine target so that every adult
should have their first dose by the end
of july you must
welcome the news absolutely welcome this
news and i think the whole country will
welcome
the news the vaccine is the light at the
end of the tunnel and
all credit to those on the front line
who've been rolling this out the nhs
have done a fantastic
job i've been to a number of vaccine
centers and it's it's very very
uplifting and i think
everybody wants to support this so this
is very welcome
so on monday the prime minister is going
to start outlining
the road map out of lockdown what
restrictions do you want to see lifted
and when well
what i want to see from the prime
minister is
um a cautious careful exit from lockdown
we all want this to be the last lockdown
so we've got to come out of it in a
measured way
but make sure that you know we're not
back where we started in a number of
weeks or months
so roll out slowly carefully
follow the science i would say the prime
minister published the science i think
that will give great confidence to what
he has to say
on monday when he puts out the road map
i think the other thing is
recognize that because there will be
ongoing restrictions of some sort
businesses desperately need more support
it's one of the reasons we've said
that the business rate relief should go
on for another six months
vat should be reduced in key areas such
as hospitality
so careful cautious follow the science
and make sure the support is there for
business they've got this far
they need to survive beyond the net set
of restrictions
of course one of the really big
decisions is around schools yeah the
government said its ambition is to open
all schools to all pupils on the 8th of
march teaching unions have said that
they are worried about that they prefer
a more staggered approach
which side is right ideally i'd like to
see all schools back open on the 8th of
march
and all children back in schools on the
8th of march i've been
worried through the pandemic a number of
people have about the impact of being
out of school has on
particularly vulnerable children and the
attainment gap is getting bigger so
ideally the 8th of march we'll have to
see
obviously where the data is see where
the science is but that's what we should
be working toward
if that means more testing if that means
nightingale classrooms if it means other
measures let's do that because
i want to get our kids back into school
so the teaching unions who are saying
that it should be staggered it should be
different year groups
you don't support that ideally we want
to see all those children back on the
8th of march that's what the prime
minister said
would happen we're going to have to go
carefully of course we are we're going
to look at the detail
and the data as we go into those weeks
just before the 8th of march see where
we are
on the infection rates but you know i've
always been concerned about the impact
on children being
out of school but you know actually i
think if we do this together we can get
through this
our political correspondent rob powell
joins me now from westminster so the
labour leader they're agreeing with the
prime minister about getting all pupils
back at once
uh will this new vaccination target that
we're hearing about now help the
government to do just that
well i think every jab julian that goes
into every arm
will help or make it a little bit easier
anyway
for the country to unlock that doesn't
mean though that this strategy being
adopted
um by the prime minister for pupils in
england all of them back on the 8th of
march that's the ambition anyway
that doesn't mean that that's not a risk
we've heard from unions this weekend
that have called the move reckless they
want a staggered approach i think it's
interesting that
the labour leader shakir stamina seems
to be setting himself
on a different track to the union saying
that he actually agrees with the prime
minister that pupil should be back in
on the 8th of march i think in reality
where we might end up
on schools is all schools open but not
necessarily all pupils in
and whilst that ambition might be
reaffirmed by boris johnson tomorrow the
reality
might look a little bit different i
think whilst teachers may prefer that on
one level there is the risk of course of
over-promising and under-delivering from
the government
i think as far as the vaccine target
goes and that new accelerated timetable
perhaps the opposite is true i think
there's a sort of widespread belief in
westminster that the government may well
be able to go even
faster than this accelerated um
timetable in terms of getting
vaccinations to everyone remember the
head of the vaccine task force earlier
this week
told sky news he thought everyone in the
country could have both of their jabs
by august or september now that would
start that would suggest that
the first jabs would be going into
everyone's arms round about the may time
um in a few months time i think part the
reason the government is perhaps
undercooking this slightly
is that they know that things can go
wrong so they don't want to miss targets
but also they know that if they start
saying that everyone will have had a jab
by the time we get to may june that will
prompt specific questions about
international travel
about summer music festivals and those
are questions the prime minister doesn't
want to answer yet
okay rob thank you the health secretary
matt hancock will be speaking to
sophie ridge on sunday this morning you
can also catch sophie's full interview
with the labour leader secretary starmer
that's all from 8 30. back now to one of
our top stories with bob johnson set to
announce his plans for the route out of
lockdown tomorrow what do small
businesses want to hear from the prime
minister
joining me now is susan moulton of
florist and stevenage who specializes in
events and andrew brack landlord
of the jubilee pub in newcastle welcome
to you both good morning
to you first of all susan um tell us and
describe for us
uh what it's been like running your
business through
the last year um
well the last year's been really really
hard um
i was looking forward to a really good
2020
uh 2020 and one by one my brides
had to postpone their weddings to the
following year and
the year after that and it was a
struggle there wasn't a lot of help
available for freelance florists
but i really really hung in there and
you know was looking forward again to
2021 being a good year
um and already up until
june my brides have postponed to 2022
um i really really hope that on monday
something will be done about the number
of people that can attend a wedding so
that my weddings can go ahead
and andrew uh similarly for you we know
that obviously uh pubs
have been closed what have the effects
been on your business
um it's been up and down because
obviously
when we could reopen after the lockdowns
last year
we did have good trading periods um
but it has been a nightmare we've got a
forward plan
for events that we do um and it's just
hard because we just don't know when
this is going to end properly
and we can do um decent outdoor
activities like we've been doing uh how
have you been managing thus far
most of your staff furloughed what what
situation are you with the star
uh all my stuff are currently furloughed
and
i'm doing takeaways on a sunday by
myself with my daughter helping
and one of my sons and i'm also helping
the two sons
doing the online burger business that
they do
but yeah all my stuff have been
furloughed and i think the photo's been
great
for uh for the industry that we've got
um
and we'll just wait to see when we can
get those back and get them working
again properly
yeah and susan how have you been
managing
because as you say you've not had uh the
the events particularly weddings which i
believe is is the
the bulk of your your trade yeah it's
it's 80 percent of my business is
weddings
um i mean i'm in a fortunate position
i've got a really supportive family
um but you know i have friends in the
industry who
don't have that and have had no help at
all
um and it is it's been really hard and
we just keep thinking oh you know
maybe it'll go ahead maybe it'll go
ahead and then it doesn't and then
brides postpone
and i mean i don't blame them they
should have the wedding they deserve
but um yeah i'm just hoping that
something's going to be said about
weddings and events
because we really need that to open back
up again
and andrew um we're all looking to what
the prime minister might say on monday
what what specifically
are you hoping for what's the the
lifeline that you really need
uh i think that really we need the pubs
to be able to open
with far fewer restrictions uh than
there have been
and even likes the table service which
is very very
labor intensive and costly and we could
deal with that coming down
a lot and i think it's it's ideal for me
to open out to
outdoors but i think a lot of the
hospitality haven't got what i've got
outside
and we need to get those open as well
but but you appreciate that that public
health is
is the the priority though don't you
oh definitely it still is the priority
and i can understand why the lockdowns
and the restrictions have taken place
but
hopefully with the vaccinations coming
through
we'll get the rates down and we'll be
able to open
susan what specifically would you like
to hear tomorrow
um yeah i mean i would i would like to
hear that
weddings can go ahead with more than 15
people
um i don't actually i think it's six um
i think if the pubs were to open and
restaurants were to open then i really
don't see
why there should be a restriction on
people at a wedding
so i'm hoping that my summer weddings
can go ahead
do you have any bookings at the the
moment that you can look forward to is
there anything on the books at all
um i have plenty of bookings but i just
can't do any of them because
each time we get close to
a wedding i've just had all my april
weddings postponed
to next year um and i had an email
yesterday from a bride who's getting
married in june and she said all fingers
crossed for monday
um and it's a really big wedding and you
know it's
i don't know i just need to know i need
to be able to plan
are my weddings going ahead or not i
need some kind of
um plan yeah andrew you're shaking your
your head there and that that's exactly
what you need you need some notice you
need
to be able to plan ahead how does it
work in terms of of stock for you
because i know
at points when pubs were open for
periods
they had stocked up and then only to be
told they have to close and they'd have
to get rid of all the all of the stock
we've been very lucky um at least my pub
off green king
and they've taken all stock back and
refunded us for that which has been very
very good
but it is it as the lady was saying it's
the forward planning that would
um to be able to plan events and
functions
as well weddings is one thing we get
parties
fortieths christians everything like
that and it is you've got to plan those
events
uh staffing and stock wise very quickly
to you both
uh first of all to you susan do you
think you'll survive this
i'm not giving up i've been doing it 34
years and i don't know how to do
anything else so
yep i'm going to hang in there andrew
letting my brother
down andrew yeah i'm
i'm hoping that we've got a very loyal
customer base and
we're a community pub so i think we will
hopefully
get the restrictions lifted a little bit
get the bars open and i think we will
force our way through we'll work through
this lovely to hear you uh
sounding so positive both thank you very
much for speaking to us this morning
thank you
thank you
now for anyone struggling with their
mental health the internet can provide
either refuge or lead to a downward
spiral
josh hendy was just 21 when he took his
own life after searching for harmful
content online
now his sister a cyber security expert
has created an online intervention tool
that she hopes will save lives either
bennett has more
alice hendy says her brother josh was
the life and soul of the party
at 21 he had so much ahead of him but in
november
he took his own life i've got really
happy memories of of my brother
i just wish he was he was still here
with me souvenirs from holidays together
are among the items alice uses to
trigger those fond memories
but after discovering how josh was able
to research suicide on the internet
before his death
she was determined to do more than just
remember him creating an online tool
to act as a safety net for others in
need of help
my main motivation for this is to
prevent other
families from going through the pain
and the complete devastation that this
causes
and if i can just save one more person
from from this
you know happening to them then as far
as i'm concerned i would have done my
job
the software alice created is called
ripple it's designed to intervene when
someone searches for harmful content
by redirecting users to a page where
they can seek help from charities
instead
the samaritan's helpline does already
appear at the top of such
searches but alice says it's not enough
what i'm trying to do is provide
much more of an interception before the
users get to those search results
and provide a range of different mental
health support options
so not just the samaritan's helpline
number that currently exists
but also a text service a web chat
facility
the downloading of resources or an app
given the impact of the pandemic on
mental health charities agree
urgent action is needed we need sites to
have robust content policies in place
that govern the type of content allowed
with effective mechanisms to remove
content that breaks their policies
or at the very least makes it much much
harder to find harmful content
online content encouraging suicide is
already illegal
and the government told sky news that
platforms must do more
to stop it appearing it's hoped the new
online harms bill will help make the
internet
a safer place by giving platforms a
legal duty of care to protect their
users
but while such legislation is welcomed
some believe
more still needs to be done iva bennett
sky news
and if you're concerned about your
mental health or anything at all that
you heard in that report you can email
the samaritans the address is
joe samaritans.org or you can call the
number
that's on the screen for you now
time now to catch up with the weather
with nas
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning so sunny sunday for many
areas but not everywhere i'm afraid
there will be some outbreaks of rain but
it's much drier affair today
across northern and western areas of the
uk island where it was
very wet indeed there are still some
blustery showers across northwest of
scotland western parts of ireland
for this morning and there are patchy
outbreaks of mostly patchy outbreaks of
rain across parts of east anglia
over to the midlands and south and east
of wales and central and southwestern
england that
area of rain will be shifting its way a
little further westwards this afternoon
towards the rest of wales northern and
uh southwestern parts of england
central england the midlands as well but
many
southern counties further towards the
southeast and east anglia as well
will brighten up and actually it will be
quite a spring-like afternoon much like
yesterday it will be
mild temperatures up to around 14 and 15
degrees celsius and bright or sunny
spells elsewhere for ireland northern
ireland
most of scotland but there will still be
the continuation of some blustery
showers
to the west of these areas
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now for botanists around the world the
last 24 hours have been extremely
exciting a rare cactus has
flowered for the first time ever in the
uk it's called a moon flower because it
usually blooms at night and the petals
only last
until the morning ali fortescue reports
deep in the amazonian basin there is a
rare flowering cactus
it's almost never been seen outside the
tropical forest
but this is cambridge where history has
today
been made i just think i think it's one
of the most astonishing flowers
the rare moon flower is thought to be
the first of its kind in the country
and more than a hundred thousand people
have been nervously waiting online for
it to bloom
it was awesome it was really awesome i
think it's one of those moments
where you've kind of been expecting it
and you've seen maybe a couple of images
but it's
more or better than anything we could
have expected
was this the most exciting moment in
your career so far
it's just the strangest thing it has the
weirdest biology
these flattened flattened stems that
grow against the side of the
the tree it has the floating seeds this
the night flowering nature of it
and the weird scent change from pleasant
scent to horrible scent so yeah it has
it all
packed into it into an amazing plant
that flowers for a very short time
we're obviously a long way from the
amazon here but this water chestnut is
just the sort of plant that the moon
flower would bloom on
in the rainforest and the temperature
here has been kept above
18 degrees so it is warm which is the
perfect condition
for the flower to bloom and the fact
that it has is really
exciting for botanists in this country
but it also means that here they can
contribute
to research about this very rare species
of cactus
strangely this flower is known for
smelling like rihanna's perfume
a smell that turns into an unpleasant
stench once flowering
is over it was never certain that this
would bloom
a plant that is famous for being shy and
unpredictable
by sunrise it will be gone a fleeting
feat
but history has already been made ali
fuldski
sky news in cambridge
and we just want to uh bring you a live
shot oh dear it is wilting i wonder how
much longer it's
got to last well the moon flower cactus
celenoceras witty that's its uh
scientific name for you
uh native to the amazon forest as we
know and one of the plants has been
growing in cambridge this plant that we
see now since
its arrival in 2015 but we think
by sunset it'll be saying goodbye
and let's see what's happening with the
weather now with now some bit sad
actually
yeah me too shall i cheer you up with
some nice weather news oh go on there
not everywhere today
but uh a lot of places will be seeing
mainly dry and bright conditions but
there will be a bit of wet weather
around as well
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning most places will be mainly
dry and bright today a lot drier than it
was
yesterday but there's still some wet
weather around across
parts of central southwestern areas of
england and wales it's light and patchy
rain and it's currently sitting across
areas of east anglia the northeast of
englandish over towards the midlands the
southeast of wales and central and
southwestern england and it's going to
shift its way a little further westwards
this afternoon
to much of southwest england wales
northern england and parts of the
midlands
but for east anglia it will brighten up
as it will do for the southeast
and for most of scotland northern
ireland of the republic it will be a
mainly dry
and sunny afternoon except for a few
blustery showers across the west of the
uk and ireland
and it's going to be mild once again in
fact it's going to feel quite
spring-like across
parts of the southeast where locally
highs of 14 to 15 degrees celsius are
likely
so yes there will be a bit of wet
weather around but for the vast majority
of the uk and ireland
it will be mainly dry and bright
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
it's 7 43 after the break we'll take a
look at the morning's newspapers with
the sunday express editor michael booker
and the broadcaster and diamond please
stay with us
[Music]
welcome back we're asked to take us
through the papers again this morning
broadcaster and diamond and the sunday
express editor michael
booker welcome back to you both starting
with the mirror and
pages four and five are backed to new
normal
a very positive story and some photos of
the celebrities that have taken the
first vaccination
yeah absolutely right they've got their
little vaccinometer there showing how
deeply
the needle has penetrated the arm of the
nation and aren't we doing well in fact
it's not just the mirror saying this all
the papers are
but what's really good about this
particular spread in the mirror
is it just sort of um spells out all the
numbers to you uh how many people have
been
uh already uh vaccinated by february the
15th
they were going to do everybody um the
70s and overs
uh already they've gone into the 65 and
overs because
i've already had mine oh well done
oh i know i had mine last week and it's
really very well done but you didn't
actually do anything
no i didn't know i know but
it was wonderful i mean the feeling in
the vaccination clinic was just so
brilliant
people were crying with relief and pride
and
just this mixture of feelings it was
just wonderful but today
as the mirror then says that we're going
on to even better targets
um hoping to get all people over 50
vaccinated
by april 15 and then all adults in the
british population
by july 31st and then it says there that
a cautious and phased road map is going
to be discussed by ministers today
uh including you know schools starting
to return march the 8th
friends and families meeting maybe the
return of the rule of six
um limited visits to care homes and you
do
question why if you've had the vaccine
and your old mum
in the nursing home has had the vaccine
and so of all the health care workers in
that
nursing why shouldn't you go and visit
her so i think things will start to open
up but it's nothing but good news
as far as that's concerned yes it does
seem very positive indeed
um and uh staying with that scientific
breakthroughs the times front page uh
mike looking at pioneering heart surgery
yeah again if you want some good news
and a good spread look in the
the times it's on page one it's on page
four and five as well and it's just
uh it cheers you up really to see that
you know obviously we're told that all
the uh
the medical facilities in this country
are under pressure but there are
some that are doing other work away from
covert this is
uh both papworth hospital where they
have heart specialists and great oldman
street and what they've been doing is
uh for the first time in children in the
world they've been using machine that
reanimates hearts
uh from donors that have already
died and they've had allowed their
hearts to die
unlike usually the the donors have come
from
brain dead patients what they do it goes
into this machine
it keeps it alive and they've been put
into i think it's six children between
the ages of 12 and 16 over the last
year have been saved by this uh and one
of them freya haddington
the great picture on the front of the
sunday times was back home in 10 days
feeling right as rain so it just goes to
show there's some great work going out
there
and it's a great positive story to put a
big spring in your step
yes yeah and uh medical breakthroughs
are abounding
onto the the mail their story science on
the brink of beating aidan
yeah this is a really interesting
feature in the mail about aids you
you think 40 odd years ago when it was
um hitting everybody so badly we were so
terrified of it
um the us is then secretary of state for
health
margaret heckler said a vaccine will be
ready uh for testing within two years
and of course that was then a prediction
that raised eyebrows then
amongst immunologists for being a little
optimistic and of course it it was
they have not come up with a vaccine for
aids until
now moderna the company that we've all
heard of as being one of the covid
vaccinators is now testing on humans
a vaccine against hiv and it just shows
that in all that time
apparently hiv was a particularly
difficult
um one to fight because um it's a
retrovirus
uh and they've fought aids in other ways
with antiretroviral drugs and different
sorts of treatment
very effectively over the last 40 years
but now there is
a vaccine on the brink of being ready
and that is incredible news too that is
amazing is i remember i'm sure you two
do those adverts back
back then which uh said don't die of
ignorance and terrified us all it's
amazing to think that a vaccination is
um about to to be available
let's um have a look at where should we
go the
male michael uh carrie simmons
speculation that she might have too much
power
yes well there has been a number of
stories over the last
few days about uh warfare in downing
street but internist sign
fights with various departments various
groups
um and carries friends versus some of
the old-school more brexity types in
downing street
this is the tory ball group which is one
of the oldest
tory think tanks but what it sounds like
is a few
dusty old tories have woken up from a
brandy and cigar fueled sleep and
discovered there's a blond-haired young
woman living in downer street and i
think
what the hell's going on here so they've
looked into this now they want a
judicial review into
just exactly what uh influence she has
uh upstairs in uh the uh the apartment
at number 11 where where they live
and uh just to see how much uh she has
to do with all the policy decisions but
no we we all know this well we all
understand that people and their
partners talk about things they will
talk about things
uh there has been as i say these
accusations flying around that she
favors certain people uh in the uh the
prime minister's team
uh we had oliver lewis leaving on uh
friday who was head of the uh
the union unit uh he was uh one of
dominic cummings's old allies
uh there was talk that the prime
minister had a row with him because
carrier told the prime minister that uh
oliver lewis had been briefing about
michael golf so it all sounds a little
bit schoolyardy
it has been dismissed by some of the
older tories in the group so
uh john redwood says he doesn't really
want to be part of this but he just goes
to shaw
they are still fighting like cats in a
sack in there when
sometimes they should be just getting on
with um you know there's a pandemic
going on you know
you can't stop a partner's influence
though can you
no not at all sure yeah it's just what
happens isn't it you get advice all the
time from a partner
and you know we yeah we've seen it
before so i'm sam cam
philip with uh philip may with uh
theresa may they all have it they're up
there as a shoulder to cry on and
someone to mull things over with and
sometimes it's your connection with real
people as well
indeed the mail this is uh intriguing
the very expensive perfume that smells
of
nothing nothing apparently
it is the the new craze the new but
apparently there is something in this
it's called molecule one and when you
buy
for 72 pounds for 100 mils it doesn't
smell of anything you can you spread on
yourself
you can't smell it at all um but other
people
do start to notice after a while
fantastic
and apparently what it is uh allegedly
so and there it doesn't seem to be any
scientific basis
in this particular story anyway is that
what it does is it sort of gets your
pheromones going your own natural
pheromones
so that what you walk around smelling
more of yourself
i guess of your natural you know
sensitivity i don't know but people say
that
you spray it on yourself you don't
notice but then after a while you notice
that people are saying
oh you smell nice today and apparently
it has some
anyway it's been it's been um
recommended by
influencers and all sorts of superstars
and it is the latest thing
the fragrance that's very expensive but
smells of nothing
possibly of you do you fancy that mike
what if you doesn't smell very nice
tell you what you wouldn't want a bottle
you wouldn't want to bottle what my
natural smell is it'd be far too
dangerous to unleash from the problem
do you think pheromones work quite like
that
and what would you think though i mean
it's it's a nice idea
but you know it's perfectly smells
differently on each individual so i mean
it really much very much depends on your
personal smell and i don't know if
everybody has a nice personal smell
no no it's but but pheromones aren't
smells are they pheromones are
chemicals that are a natural um i don't
know
they're just i think i think they're a
sort of sexual chemical aren't they
um
an industry insider who said i bought it
sprayed it on myself got in the taxi cab
went home and thought this is ridiculous
i've wasted this money on nothing
but then within half an hour everybody
around her started to say oh you smell
nice today
oh my gosh michael you want to get
yourself out there and get some ball
i'm going to buy some snake bottle as
well thank you both for taking us
through the papers this morning
good to see you as always thanks so much